welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
bring you the best games of the day so
you can make up your own mind one thing
many of you been asking is when Ghost
Recon wildlands ghost war PvP will
finally drop and also is it too late
well you'll have to answer the second
part of that question for yourself we
have played ghost war and here our
thoughts ghost war is 4v4 team
deathmatch with revives each match is
best of three with 10 minute rounds
apiece ghost war takes place lugs small
to medium sized maps and will have 12
classes with 8 maps at launch the
current offering is soldiers and small
arms only which is a bit of a
disappointment because of any game beg
for vehicles an objective based PvP
outside of battlefield it's probably
this game there is an unlocked tree for
players to earn weapons and perks as
they go the matches themselves take
place on maps that typically have open
outer areas a central town with a radio
tower and some interior spaces it's not
hard to find the enemy team using either
your binoculars the Scout drone or the
higher risk idea if one team activates
the central radio tower the other team
becomes spotted this mechanic keeps
matches flowing and avoids any kind of
extended camping one cool touch was
dynamic weather which could change
visibility and may cause players to use
gadgets such as thermal vision the six
classes we saw in our demo or assault
marksman support and grunt all of which
come in two subclasses I can't show you
the menus but some of them had
interesting abilities the marksman
sniper is the only player that can shoot
through cover the scouts are the only
ones with drones that can chase the
enemy team around the map and drop more
strikes on them and the assault tank can
take spotting off of his entire team and
place it on himself there was also a
generic grunt which had no abilities but
did have some strong weapons like an
ak-47 and the only other designated
marksman rifle I loved playing support
and when a buncha rounds just chasing
the enemy team around with a drone so
what do you all think is team deathmatch
what you were looking for or do you have
some great ideas for the devs speak up
in the comments below and throw us the
old thumbs up or consider subscribing to
our Channel let's get to some gameplay
of Ghost Recon wildlands ghost war PvP
Gibson don't forget that you can
actually shoot through some covers so if
we've got a good line on some people a
good mark
I'll actually you should be able to hit
them there's some walls and stuff so I'm
seeing gopher is uh alright guys see
them all take a lot of guys over here
just suppressing okay they're all right
there he's running
let me see all right how you guys doing
good
I lost them though oh yeah good okay
over there I would go for the recon
Tower which would actually mark all the
enemies on the map but I unfortunately
cannot refer to do that because they all
have a really good line of sight on the
recon tower all right all right so
there's a couple of them right there
they're both kind of let's see I wanna
see - okay it is just those two
okay so Gophers going for that oh you
get up not just one okay all right let's
play keys gonna go for survive you got
him nice nicely done guys that's how you
do it oh yeah they definitely coming up
more towards me yeah see where I'm
pinging on the map yeah yeah yellow dot
yeah where I just pinged white that's
where they're in that general vicinity
okay oh you know what there's a side row
back Oh
marks I need to get back to cover oh and
there's a sniper over there oh this is
not looking good
somebody can take care that sniper
Vipers down okay Scout drones out but
they know I'm here
all right I'm sending our drone up to
cool still two of them and we don't know
I mean they've got to be close to us
Gibson here
reload and give me a second okay
knockdowns 100 meters out that way
cheerfully I'm gonna keep him in there
if you want to charge quarters going
down and now Oh
o out there too
I'm not gonna retreat I'm gonna retreat
I've got really bad positioning right
here yes run back to the one of the
crates and they're marching white okay
let me cover your retreat rook Lee has a
far enough away it's hard to shoot Oh
perfect
okay we got a knockdown coming off the
back hill right by you moon dog
that's Winky he's out okay doc down by
moon dog
yeah knockdowns on my position okay okay
I got one more here who's gonna go for
Twinkie all right Chuck ins out
okay I might need some assistance in
this area I know there's two around here
somewhere somebody can get the drone up
and we're spot-on nugget coming up now
okay I know they're close I just don't
know exactly where there should be two
in this area see anything oh there's oh
there's two out there okay Adam I don't
know where their drone guy is but oh
yeah one I grab looper before he can uh
get the other one back
Gophers up there
[Music]
watch it they got a drone looking for us
I placed a mind for our Sicario friends
right down
we go
sit down here got one take you back
powers back on
man down man down I got you
[Applause]
[Music]
you